Щиро вітаємо вас це програма У фокусі
Європи і телекомпанії Deutsche Welle це
буде найважча зима в нашій історії
такими словами Український президент
Зеленський готує земляків до найближчих
місяців
але вже зараз ситуація дуже напружена
ті у кого ще є дах тут головою шукають
серед Завалів дрова для опалення багато
українців готується до найгіршого позаяк
у зруйнованих містах не працює Ні
постачання електроенергії ні опалення
наразі російська армія прицільно знищила
майже 40% української енергопостачання
на сході України вз фронту ситуацію
особливо складна
хоча Українські війська змогли вибити
російських окупантів з міста Леванте і
околиць але люди сидять буквально на
руїнах житлові будинки зруйновані
постійно переривається водопостачання
електро та газозабезпечення однак попри
весь свій здебільшого перемагає радість
від повернутої Свободи
бути вагітною Це мабуть є великим щастям
для багатьох жінок але що робити якщо
вони не можуть або не хочуть виношувати
дитину у більшості європейських країн
жінки самі вирішують Чи хочуть вони
робити аборт у Польщі ж усе інакше
законодавство там одне з найсуворіших у
Європі проти цього бореться Юстина
віржинська і вона дуже ризикує
активістів що відстоює право на аборти
загрожує тривалу ув'язнення але юстинна
бореться не одна
[музика]
та й ніколи не будеш самотньою
демонстрантки перед варшавським судом
хочуть продемонструвати свою
Солідарність З Юстиною видружинською є
загрожує до трьох років в'язниці за те
що вона поділила своїми таблетками для
переривання вагітності щоб допомогти
одній жінці у Польщі ці таблетки
заборонені
мужність у Юстини видрожицької
захоплюється багато молодих жінок
оскільки вона та її мережа борються за
самовизначення та проти одного з
найбільш обмежувальних законів про
аборти в Європі той хто це робить має В
католицькій Польщі багато ворогів
Я ніколи не думала що так нервуватиму
але я дуже нервуюсь я приходжу в суд без
почуття провини те що я зробила На мою
думку було доброю справою бо людям треба
допомагати Сьогодні я хочу представляти
всіх тих хто допомагає один одному
навіть у такій складній ситуації як
аборт матері своїм донькам доньки своїм
матерям подруги одна одній
колись в одержинська надіслало одній
жінці власні таблетки для переривання
вагітності за це її зараз засудять її
зворушила доля жінки каже Вона і
нагадала їй про власний аборт
тут у своєму рідному місті в часниш 17
років тому тоді вона вже мала трьох
дітей і знову завагітніла вона застрягла
у шлюбі в якому почувалася
контрольованою і пригніченою
у мене було відчуття що коли я це
зробила коли переривала вагітність я
звільнилась
відновила контроль над своїм тілом а
також контроль над своїм життям життям
своїх дітей
так і сталося я подумала коли давала
жінці свої таблетки що з нею відбудеться
те ж саме
що варто боротися за власну автономію
і Юстина видружинська вважає що
законодавство про аборти в Польщі є
ворожим щодо жінок її доньці сільвії 18
років дівчина відчула що таке жити
стамбу
інформування про статеве життя дорівнює
нулю
перед усім у моїй школі де про це не
говорять одного разу на уроці релігії ми
порушили з пастором теми абортів і
пастор не дозволив нам висловлювати свою
думку і так відбувається завжди тема
просто якомога швидше обривається
наразі аборту Польщі дозволений лише в
тому випадку якщо вагітність становить
загрозу життю чи здоров'ю матері або є
результатом зґвалтування
і Устина видружинська заснувала мережу
допомоги що консультує польських жінок
які не можуть або не хочуть виношувати
дитину з інших причин вона надає
інформацію про сайти де жінки можуть а
замовити таблетки для переривання
небажаної вагітності
вони відправляють їх поштою з
європейських країн прямо За вказаними
адресами
ми як інші організації що працюють у
Польщі ніколи не розповсюджуємо ліки ми
лише надаємо інформацію
торік за допомогою до польських жіночих
організацій звернулися 34 тисячі жінок
також тисячі польських жінок зробили
аборти за кордоном а видружинська та
інші активістки організували спеціальну
зустріч обмін досвідом польських жінок
які зробили аборт у центрі Варшави
я не шкодую про своє рішення мені лише
Шкода що воно приймалося в Польщі за
спинами лікарів уряду і в моєму випадку
моєї сім'ї
тоді я була молодою лікаркою
працювала в найближчій лікарні і боялася
як що я раптом втраплю в халепу то можу
втратити роботу і свою ліцензію
Юстина вдружинська сподівається що
одного дня ситуація в Польщі зміниться
для цього вона хоче і надалі допомагати
жінкам які опинились у складному
становищі навіть якщо вона знає
наскільки високим є ризик
допомагати людям хочу також і він ще
йомус Бараш лікару Туреччині його
професія є для нього покликанням однак
він залишив роботу у лікарні бо пережив
там жахливі речі
на відкритті великої клініки в анкарі
президент Туреччини ердоган хвалиться
своєю системою охорони здоров'я
перетновою будівлею
проте за фасадом усе виглядає зовсім
інакше
особливо лікарям Все частіше доводиться
жити з відчутними наслідками
щоранку у шейму Збараж одягає кухонний
фартух щоб допомогти матері у сімейному
ресторані
хоча у цей час він мав би носити білий
халат оскільки Бараш є за професією
лікарем кілька місяців тому він ще
працював у відділенні невідкладної
медичної допомоги у Великій лікарні на
сході Туреччини
допоки Одного разу його не почали ганяти
по коридорах і бити родичі одного
пацієнта
жорстокість сцени зафіксували камери
відеоспостереження раніше пацієнт
поскаржився на послуги лікарні
коли я сказав йому що він не робив Він
накинувся на мене
я відбивався Але його дружина покликала
з двору решту сім'ї
І вони всі почали мене бити
травматичний досвід для молодого лікаря
насправді він любить свою професію але
відтоді Бараш уникає лікарні
за даними дослідження кожен четвертий
працівник турецької системи охорони
здоров'я хоча б раз зазнавав фізичного
насильства під час виконання службових
обов'язків
Минулого року працівникам лікарень по
всій країні довелося викликати охорону
понад 100 тисяч разів
на мітингу профспілки лікарів Бараш на
знак протесту розриває свій диплом і
халат
у цій країні до академічної освіти ще
ніколи не ставилися так зневажливо як
зараз
але є й інші причини зростання
насильства проти медичних працівників
зустрічі з колегами по профспілці
лікарів
на стіні фото колеги якого нещодавно
убили
насильство пов'язане також із умовами
праці особливо у державних лікарнях
коли лікар повинен приймати до 150
пацієнтів на день виникають певні
проблеми
ми взагалі не можемо виправдати
очікування пацієнтів щодо працездатної
системи охорони здоров'я
барашу допомогла Солідарність колег А ще
йому допомогли також її здалекою
Фінляндії після інциденту
лікар-турецького походження запропонував
йому роботу
відтоді він вивчає фінську мову
Насправді я хотів поїхати за кордон щоб
пройти інтернатуру
але тепер я вирішив покинути країну
назавжди
і він не перший
експерти попереджають про справжній
відтік молодих добре підготовлених
лікарів
на цьому знімку зустріч молодих
турецьких лікарів в екзилі влітку у
Дюссельдорфі
якщо вони хочуть їхати то Нехай їдуть
Ми продовжуємо йти нашим шляхом і з
новими лікарями з наших університетів
у вухах потерпілих лікарів це звучить як
насмішка
позаяк життя з фізичними нападами
образами та погрозами накладає свій
відбиток
а вони завжди підозрюють
вони заново переживають усі події і
бояться своєї роботи
будь-яке гучне слово може викликати у
них паніку
від нападу досі страждає також і
шеймузбараж хай там як але покарання за
насильницькі дії щодо медичних
працівників посилили і його нападників
засудили у першій інстанції до трьох з
половиною років позбавлення волі
про свої перші успіхи він може
розповісти стурбованій матері
тепер Принаймні я трохи краще сплю
у перші кілька тижнів я міг спати не
довше двох годин поспіль
вважає що криза у турецькому секторі
охорони здоров'я повинна позбавляти сну
політиків у всякому разі до свого
від'їзду до Фінляндії він воліє поки що
працювати на кухні
водійський Альпи на висоті понад тисячі
метрів
навіть якщо ця картина все ще відображає
ідеальний світ глобальне потепління
спричинене нами людьми має руйнівний
вплив на гірський ландшафт
одне лише спекотне літо 2022 року
спричинили вальпах рекордне танення
особливо постраждав ронський льодовик у
швейцарському кантонії Вале його
величезні шрильоду з кожним роком
зменшується
які залишилися варіанти щоб зупинити
танення зараз швейцарські вчені вдаються
до нетрадиційних методів
[музика]
це майже безсила спроба все-таки
зупинити нестримне роінський льодовик
покритий брезентом тому що він все
швидше Тане минулої зими майже не було
снігу Літо почалося вже у березні і було
дуже жарко зміна клімату язик льодовика
продовжує рух угору під ним утворилося
озеро Вчені з технічного університету
цюриха намагаються вимірювати повільну
смерть льодовика
на початку цього літа ми побачили великі
зміни
ФФУ є ми підозрюємо що тут під
льодовиком тобто біля основи утворилася
печера крижаний покрив став дуже тонким
і тому просідає
зверху пригріває сонце А знизу
льодовиковий потік гризе лід
вчені сверблять у ньому отвори опускають
у них датчики тиску і температури а
також опускають камери щоб точніше
зрозуміти чому льодовик тане Все швидше
тепер коли рідна поверхня стає все
томшим лід на льодовику починає
просідати там унизу річка практично
вирвалась назовні дах льодовика
обвалився і тепер він поступово
відступає ця велика воронка - це кратер
повільно опускається і Можливо якщо не
цього літа то наступного він точно
з'єднається Отже відбувається поступовий
відступ коли озеро наближається а
льодовик поступово відступає
ронський льодовик відступає якщо
Кліматичні зміни продовжуватимуться
такими штампами то як побоюються
експерти до кінця століття нічого не
залишиться
у Альпах страждають усі льодовики Вчені
з технічного університету цюриха
підрахували що з 1931 року швейцарські
льодовики втратили половину свого об'єму
це задокументовано у Долині мортирач у
гравюндені де спостереження ведуться
упродовж 146 років
з 1876 року і до сьогодні і якщо нічого
не зміниться то до кінця століття це
виглядатиме так
танення оголює катастрофи минулих часів
невеликі літак який розбився на
льодовику Але чи У 1968 році
і завжди породжує також нові катастрофи
зокрема обвал льодовика у доломітових
Альпах 3 липня від льодовика Мармелада
відкололась величезна брила льоду
загинули 11 людей
і це танення рукотворне глобальне
потепління а також забруднення довкілля
упродовж більш ніж 150 років адже чорний
шар який покриває лід складається не
лише з кам'яного пилу
темними є також частинки сажів які потім
утворюють таку собі жирну масу яка
залишається зверху і впливає негативно
на все оскільки вона темніша то поглинає
більше сонячного світла
це означає що виділяється додаткове
тепло яке змушує льодовик танути ще
швидше це призводить до парадоксального
ефекту у спекотне посушливе літо Рона
несе більше води ніж зазвичай а не менше
поки не розтануть льодовики
для воду та енергопостачання Швейцарії
це мало бруйнівні наслідки
60% електроенергії країна виробляє з
гідроенергії
якоюсь мірою це боляче що в політиці
більше не б'ють на сполох
адже саме час запровадити справді
ефективні заходи із захисту клімату
тиснути на політику повинна також і
населення
бо сама політика цього не виправить
щоб стримати танення часу залишається
небагато
щоб зупинити танення величезні
пасажирські літаки такі як Airbus
повинні літати без викидів CO2
про це мрії один французький винахідник
інженер Жан бетис луазле він
покладається на енергію сонця та вітру
за своїми сонячного планері він налітав
вже Тисячі кілометрів виключно на
відновлювальній енергії і він твердо
вірить що його технологія може бути
використана також на великих літаках
Я мрію подорожувати на далекій відстані
куди хочу при цьому не забруднюючи нашу
планету
І я відчуваю що знаходжусь на
правильному шляху Це просто чудово
жабатист луазле перебуває в повітрі вже
5 годин сьогодні він подолав відстань у
2220 км він повинен бути там попереду А
ось і він
Західна посадку угроле на півдні Франції
15 етап його повітряного Тур де Франс
ЛуАЗ зле рекламує свій проект Вінкс
Forza Planet тобто крила для планети
[музика]
який політ
заради подібних вражень ланцюрист та
інженер залишив роботу і присвятив все
виключно своєму сонячному літаку
скрізь є допитливі люди вони хочуть
знати як це може працювати
мій планер злітає сам за допомогою цього
пропелера який виглядає маленьким але
має один метр у діаметрі він живиться
від батарей а вони заряджаються від
сонячних батарей встановлених на крилах
луазле працював над літаком три роки і
вклав усі свої заощадження у будівництву
прототипу
Я вражений все-таки гладеньке він
повністю інтегрував сонячні батареї в
крилах
я інженерка і Пілот тому приблизно має
уявлення про роботу яка за цим стоїть і
я вважаю що це чудово Це породжує мрії
мрії про сприятливі для клімату польоти
без виділення бодай одного грама СО2 це
сучасність адже Мій літак уже літає
підготовка до наступного етапу
Монпельє на піксенлу або я лечу через
Приморське Альпи інженер любить і
природу і техніку Спочатку він розробляв
підводну роботу техніку проте одного
разу молодий Альбатрос Біля південного
полюса надихнув його на польоти
альбатросів фантастичні вони надихнули
мене і я сказав собі що Одного
прекрасного дня я захочу літати як вони
цього разу лугазли облітає всю Францію
це понад 2000 кілометрів
таким він бачить туриз майбутнього
Зараз я перебуваю на висоті 7 тисяч
футів над монсен Мішель в авіаційній
промисловості багато хто вважає його
божевільним бо луазли переконаний що
кліматично нейтрально тобто На сонячній
енергії будуть колись літати навіть
великі літаки із сотнями пасажирів
Звісно що сьогодні важко собі уявити
Boeing чи Airbus із сонячними батареями
але сучасні сонячні батареї
використовують лише 20% сонячної енергії
через 10-20 років це може бути 40-60%.»
[музика]
До побачення грали мій Тур де Франс
скоро завершиться
але Піонер в авіації вже планує свій
наступний тур по всій Європі щоб
надихати все більшу кількість людей на
польоти з енергією сонця
мене всякому разі він своєї ідеєю уже
надихнув це було програму У фокусі
Європи і телекомпанії Deutsche Welle
Дякуємо за ваші інтерес залишайтеся
здоровими і до побачення
українською мовою озвучено центром
медіа-ініціатив переклад Володимира та
Олесі Швед режисер Павло Тимченко так
читали Олена потоцька Юрій Лисенко та
Олесь гоян Київ 2022 рік